hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about language learning
and i want to talk about something that
i often think of and i've been meaning
to do a video on and that is what i
would call the placebo effect in
language learning placebo p-l-a-c-e-b-o
that's what they call
um the sort of when they test a new
medicine they typically give
say half the
uh people they're testing
uh the new medicine
and another half a placebo which looks
like the medicine but in fact doesn't
have any medicinal ingredients
um
and when they test people they find that
if there are three groups let's say
those who took the medicine those who
took the placebo which is an imitation
medicine and those who took nothing
that
if the medicine is effective then the
people who took the medicine will do
better
the people who took the placebo will do
next
best and the people who do did nothing
do less well so
even those
who think they have the medicine are
going to do better
because our belief
in
the power of say a pill or something
influences us because everything inside
us is influenced
by
how we feel what we think
and in in language learning it's exactly
the same way i know that i'm a better
language learner today
uh in my 70th year than i was at the age
of 16 because i know i can do it
and i'm confident that i'm going to
succeed
but it's not only that
i know that the method i'm using is
effective i know that reading
is very good for my language learning
right now i'm reading a long novel in
spanish it's called di mekien soy and
it's a very interesting spy thriller
takes place in a historical you know
civil war in spain second world war and
stuff but i know that just the fact of
reading this book is going to do so much
for my spanish improve it i'm
exposing myself to certain patterns to
words and stuff
but if i don't believe that reading is
good for my spanish and right now i'm
not really working on spanish it's just
that i happen to come across this book
and i'm reading it but it was the same
when i was learning czech
very early on i started reading this
book on czech history even though there
were a lot of words that i didn't know
in which i didn't look up
but i know from experience that as i and
because i have some sense of the history
so as i read through this thing it's not
only enjoyable but it makes me feel good
because i know that it's going to
improve my check so
if we now some of you may not like to
read i i happen to believe that reading
and then listening when you don't have
the the ability to focus on
on on just the one task
but i happen to know that that's that's
very effective i believe it's very
effective now if you believe other
things are effective if you believe that
uh
you know pimsleur is effective if you
believe that asimil is effective if you
believe that
you know anki is effective whatever it
is if you believe it that's going to
help you learn that our attitude towards
the task as i've said so many times you
know that we like the language that
we're confident stuff but even to the
extent that you have to believe in the
method the learning method and and one
of the difficulties we have at link is
to persuade people that just by doing
the things that we ask them to do just
by reading
and listening and saving words and
reviewing these words and then
eventually talking to people that that's
going to
improve their
language skills
if they don't believe that
hey they won't stay with it but b
it's that placebo effect just as with
these tests of the effectiveness of
medicine if you believe in the medicine
if you believe in the method you will do
better so whatever your favorite method
is
believe in it
and stay with it
and you will learn better so
by the way one final thing i'm happy to
do some of these in other languages
which languages would you like to hear
me speak in spanish chinese japanese
french russian german swedish whatever
let me know i will try my best even in
fact if i happen to stumble while
speaking in those languages bye for now